[Music]
hmm
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games we
got some good games for you here some
real spookers if you ask
me and i bet you do so thanks for tuning
in and get ready for some great
scary games starting off right now
[Music]
all right so this is the basement
it's supposed to be inspired by pt or
maybe just like pt woo
hello hi well aren't you delightful
uh so i'm guessing that i i'm looking
down
oh yeah
hello someone dancing over here
sure seems like someone's dancing
[Music]
hello where is that even coming from oh
over there
oh god zuke's uh okay
hey what's up hey oh good
oh you're in there oh okay
um oh you're not there anymore
oh okay oh man maybe i should have tried
to peekaboo through the little
little gap right there but apparently
not okay well
that's disturbing
which is good in a horror game
[Music]
i don't like shadows moving you know
that's something that
i don't usually see in a lot of horror
games mostly just because
you know they don't have the kind of
graphical fidelity to really play with
shadows very much but i don't usually
see that
ah unsettling there's
it's just crossing over into a realistic
sense that i don't appreciate
oh hey
okay oh what is that
oh yeah oh we're doing this aren't we
oh we're doing this aren't we oh we're
doing this
you dancing in there oh i probably could
have seen something i didn't even try to
look
i'm a fool i'm a fool in love
with you
don't make a sound
will fall okay okay okay
okay okay you got it buddy
you got it pal looks like someone
flipped the table in rage but that's
okay
this is all great this is really good
stuff um
oh no oh no
okay all right all right
yeah surely that's not gonna break okay
all right
hope you think those chains are strong
very happy about that um anybody in
there
peekaboo peek-a-boo i see you
i can't see damn okay
all right yeah i'll i'll i'll go around
i'll go around
i'll go around yeah i'll go around i
don't like the way that's flickering oh
look a key oh thanks for me
thank you now what is this a key to
to this thing definitely not no way
hello
well someone's sassy unless that was me
that did that
in which case i'm the sassy one
okay well goodbye
have a lovely day thank you
candles i think that's new anybody
dancing
okay
oh yeah
yeah that's fine all right good stuff
hey what's up you broke the water ah
damn it uh
i feel bad about that it's like some
paint supplies
and then darkness there could be
something in that darkness and i would
never know
so that was just a random happenstance
you know could have happened at any
moment those chains were so way
light light light why light bright light
white light bright tonight
okay yeah uh-huh
yeah i'm uh yeah it's just nothing
that's the thing
just i think that was him
it's fine henry you got to stop barking
when i'm playing horror games
very scary very scary this still broke
dude
oh yes still broke dude someone in there
now
peekaboo iggy will i see you
peekaboo
why would there be anybody there
[Laughter]
all good nothing to worry about here all
good
oh no is that open
hey don't run away from me don't you
dare run away from me
oh you will not run away from me you
running away from me huh
well you should be afraid of me i'm very
terrifying
i've been known to
hey [ __ ] it's not breaking my stuff
i'm assuming it's mine maybe it is maybe
not did to drop a key or something
i'm just gonna go back and try the first
store just because
maybe it wants me to do that i do not
know
and i'm willing to take my time all
right
okay all right sounds good well
i don't see any there we go got it got
it got it got it
give give give easy peasy thank you me
easy
maybe that was thrown from the window
when it was broken but i didn't notice
it before oh you're open again huh
oh you're open again oh i don't even
need the key huh
oh i don't even need the key oh i didn't
even need it
i didn't even need it all right i'm
coming for you
oh i don't like this it's very dark oh
very dark
a paradigm what we wanted as you see
what why why
whoa
okay i'm dealing with this i'm dealing
with this
i'm dealing with you [ __ ] you want to
fight
i'm bigger than you i'll fight you okay
okay well this thing's new was this here
before
lovely lovely place i could have taken
that thing whatever it was i could have
taken it
you think you're special you're not
you're not special you're not special
not to me
not to me not to me oh open huh
open up oh yeah open huh you open huh
oh what's going on with the floor
i told you that water leak was going to
be a problem
basement isn't exactly waterproof
yeah you better run silence
something silence will fall ah that's
probably silence we'll fall
okay come at me startle [ __ ]
is that all you can do startle can't
even hurt me can you
can't even hurt me can you hmm
oh come on it's open okay it's closed
never mind
thought it was open
somebody down here come on startled
[ __ ]
huh
no that's all you can do huh you can't
even hurt me huh
didn't think so didn't think so
that's interesting oh
hello i'll come for you
i'll come for you in the night okay all
right all clear coast is clear
i don't have to go find someone in the
middle of the night to destroy them
and i will i will do it and conveniently
it is currently the middle of the night
so i can destroy anybody you want
well that's a different glow
i'm here [ __ ] come at me
i thought that was footsteps charging
down the way at me i'm ready to face my
demise
i will come for you i'll come to you
try me now try me immediately now
do it [ __ ]
you think you're
don't know what that was all about but i
don't care either
oh boy hey who's knocking
knock on your door i'll knock on your
face
this water's getting a bit of a problem
huh
water's kind of a thick water's kind of
thick huh
damn that water be looking thick though
wasn't this bright in here before oh
that's interesting has it always been
there
well that's a problem come at me i'm
coming
come on i'm ready oh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you locked me in here
all right oh
oh you locked me in here
huh oh you think that i'm done oh no
you think i am the monster in this one
you just lock the monster in the
closet i'ma come find you okay we're
done we're out of here
well that was very good and i've learned
something about myself if a monster ever
does approach me i will just
i'll fight it i will fight it i'll fight
it as hard as i can
which is very hard exactly this hard
hi spongebob how you doing down there
welcome to sponge massacre
no i'm not unfamiliar with spongebob
creepypasta horror games um but this one
seems to be taking a bit of a different
twist where spongebob himself is the
problem
spongebob hasn't gone to work in a very
long time
he's been acting suspicious bikini
bottom police got a call from mr krabs
he's reported strange noises coming from
his home
the next day patrick squidward and sandy
were reported missing bikini bottom
police decided to raid spongebob's house
you play as one of the police officers
of the bikini bottom police
woz left e f
okay
freaking come out with your hands up
all right um hey dudes you know honestly
this looks kind of true to form for
spongebob
hey what's what's up man hey how's it
going how's everyone doing over here
invisible all right okay uh you guys
cover me
i'll go in i guess
yeah it seems safe find seven krabby
patties to open the secret door in the
kitchen
i don't know if i want to do that i
think i'm here to
you know oh my goodness
i thought i was here to like you know
rescue people all right
so apparently there's some krabby
patties around here
anybody over there spongebob
gary
holy [ __ ] oh my god
[Music]
okay uh this is officer
iplier requesting backup immediately
i picked up a krabby patty well i don't
feel too confident about that
what am i looking at on the other side
of that wall oh hey gary
gary hey what's up
hey what's up gary you okay gary
sorry sorry gary sorry
you seem fine bang oh
hi hi patrick what's up dude
okay
okay that's fine turn on your flashlight
with the f key
yeah i knew yeah i knew about that
oh no oh no
oh no patrick no
okay well seems fine
man it looks bigger on the inside that
it did on the outside this pineapple
goes
hi good
okay i don't know how many that makes i
think it might be four but
not completely sure
okay oh my god
good thing bullets work underwater
okay that's weird barnacle boy oh no
how'd this car get in your mouth now
this boat get in here
okay there's no sandwich there there's
no sandwiches all right okay uh barnacle
boy i'll i'll get you help eventually i
guess
oh that's a trap that looks like a trap
this looks like a trap it all looks like
a trap
it's all a trap it's trapped down there
it's trapped down here
i'll take this trap
who's at the end of the hall who is that
who are you
reveal yourself oh sandy oh no
oh no sandy
[Music]
bang gucci
okay well i guess that's just that way
now
okay got a krabby body i got a krabby
patty any other krabby patty down here
grab it oh there's another one
okay i think there's just one more oh
god is this the last one
no is there one more than i need is that
what the deal is
okay well i saw one down at that long
hallway that looked
okay hey plankton i saw one down this
long hallway that looked like a trap i
mean it definitely absolutely was a trap
but you know i'm gonna let that slide
for now hey what's up
how you doing
oh no
okay okay
i see a crabby body this is gonna be
good for me
not oh i don't wanna i don't wanna i'm
gonna do it oh no i did it oh god i did
it
oh
i knew it i knew it was a drink i knew
it
i knew it i knew how did i knew
all right i'm gonna try that again
you're not gonna get me that easily you
think i'm just gonna let you get me
okay whatever whatever i'm gonna speed
run this [ __ ]
try me try me try me try make sure i'm
returning
that's what i thought that's what i
thought two this is two
okay that was two i'm going to count
this time i'm real good at counting
well this is three this would be four
four
let me go get that crowbar in case i
need i don't think i need the one at the
end of that haul there
because that seems like a trick just
seems like a trick to me
so this would be five five and
six somewhere six six
seven so this is all i need so i don't
need to go down that hallway because i'm
willing to bet that's probably just
death okay so now i can go back and i
can get the door open
i don't need to be here anymore hi gary
whoa wait a minute what the hell what is
that don't try to leave it's too late
i'm out oh god but i have a cribber
i have the grouper i have the grouper i
have the kruber
oh [ __ ] oh hi oh
uh okay
[Music]
mr squarepants i'm afraid you're under
arrest
oh my god there was a lot of blood in
you what the [ __ ]
all right well that didn't sound like
spongebob
not sure about this change of voice
actor we got in here oh good
engine two of two you left spongebob's
house confused and scared spongebob got
what he deserved he killed nine people
in four days
never thought this would happen i guess
the demons got to him spongebob's
patrick's and squidward's houses were
abandoned bikini bottom is traumatized
i never did find out what happened to
patrick i just saw him and then he was a
bloodstain but nobody so
great good game good game
god man fun times
all right moving on
ronald ronnie i don't know what's with
the theme
of turning beloved beloved childhood
characters
of corporate entities you know if you
look back at some of the
mcdonald's mascots they are pretty
creepy and and i don't like them very
much so
this is not a big surprise oh this is a
lovely informational screen it's so
bright and vivid
oh i love it okay whatever let's make it
happen
oh yeah oh yeah oh oh
yeah oh yeah
i love the look of this i i just want to
say that straight up i
love the look of this this is fantastic
this is super cool
i am into this all right well
la dee dee la dee da i'm going into
mcdougalls
hey no story here no backstory
no uh informational blurbs that i need
to know about wait what am i even doing
am i
able to get in here hello
hi hi you guys oh good the back door's
open
well um i don't really see where you
guys cook the food
okay here the turlet
[Music]
what is that oh
oh i got a saw pliers and a hammer
why did i get a saw pliers
and a hammer i'm more than a little
confused
but you know technically nothing out of
the ordinary here
except that i'm in a completely
abandoned parking lot hello
hi why is your vehicle on okay well
this game gets points for ambiance
but if ronald comes charging at me from
the darkness i'm going to be
extremely upset okay i guess i go
towards the big old supermarket
okay oh this is
oh this is lovely
oh this is delightful
oh good
food products from the land of the free
holy crap something about the lighting
in the fall
really really makes this look
unsettling oh hello holy cow dairy
products okay
so uh i still don't know what i'm
supposed to do
i don't exactly have an objective so
oh no oh no
oh no
okay we're fine oh we are fine
oh we are fine oh good i'm so
happy i'm so happy about that oh
i'm not happy about whatever's happening
to my eyeballs
hello oh no
oh no oh no
i really don't know why all these tools
are in this mcdonald's
yeah i don't know why i grabbed them
wait okay what if i use
the hammer no
no there's no key okay so i don't think
i have one i need to get that
no ronnie ronnie
ronnie boy ron
[Music]
ron
ronaldo
okay just the backyard oh happy meal
well that's good i'm what am i looking
at
okay i'm gonna pretend like i never saw
that
i'm gonna pretend like that never
happened
we're all gonna pretend like that never
okay i see another happy meal in there i
don't know
why i'm collecting all the happy meals
but i sure am aren't i i sure
am i really am okay there's a
pumpkin okay that's oh good i got a
pumpkin okay all right yeah
uh-huh
no no no
no uh the thing about no
the thing is no the thing is
no oh hey there's a happy meal here
i'm just gonna please do not kill me oh
my god
so it was not worth that happy meal all
right um
let's try that again i did not like him
uh why why now
no you don't where are you you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] okay so it's like slendy as
soon as you get the first one he starts
coming after you but without all the
sounds okay
no no
no you will not
you will not oh you will not oh my god
you will not
oh go away okay thank you
i know he's just gonna probably just
come after me but
whatever i'm alive for now oh
oh oh my god i'm sorry everybody i
panicked a little bit i didn't expect
him to be right there
hello
does he appear when my flashlight is
down
oh hey bud man you are fun
oh you're so fun um but uh no
i thought i thought oh [ __ ] i thought
okay um just not gonna pay attention to
you
ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
okay so we're fine i thought there was
one
on the ground here wasn't there
maybe it's just a bunch of possible
locations
oh boy hey bud how you doing um
don't mind me don't mind me well you're
gone okay
don't don't mind me okay uh
hoping he's not like right around this
corner i'm really hoping
oh god he was just right around the
corner
one more try one more try and this time
i'm not gonna grab
a happy meal right off the bat i'm gonna
go get whatever the tools are that i
need what does that
look that looks out of place
polaroid camera what is that for could i
flash him
maybe i could flash ronald and he'd
leave me alone
the trick just seems like you oh hey
well that's here um i'll make that the
last one it's very symbolic
uh maybe i could just flash him and get
it over with i probably want to get the
stuff that's
inside first because there's definitely
a lot of like dead ends and stuff that
would get me caught up
um by cuteness oh
hell yeah all right let me just get an
eye of where everything is
god i wish i could hold my light
straight okay i'm just gonna go for it
screw it there we go no time for
strategy here
oh hey bud
[Laughter]
anything behind there no okay good hey
ron
how you doing ron oh i gotta go get the
one in the bathroom or something
probably there's one over there okay
there's another one
okay run
run oh i hate that
any in here ah oh that's four
that's four already who where where okay
where is he
where are you [ __ ] where
are you oh where is he i can't i can't
find him
oh my god he's gonna get me i'm just
gonna go outside
that had to have been the majority of
him oh there he is
okay i'm gonna go out the back i'm gonna
go at the back and everything's gonna be
good
and in here honey in here come on come
on quickly quickly
let's see oh there we go that's five
pretty good okay there was oh there was
none in there okay there was none there
okay five is good and you're on oh yeah
six is good
plus the one in the the
building that's almost all of them
[Laughter]
did you guys even see him you guys
didn't see him yeah because he was a
he was there okay where is he oh god
where is he
where is he i don't see him oh he's
right around the corner isn't he
oh my god oh he is oh my god he was
what what what what
what ah pumpkin
i don't know is there any like item i
can use against him or what is the deal
i have no idea i need to get two more i
don't know if the game is over once i
get two more but i need two more
i think my screaming is deterring him
oh my god i have no idea where the last
one is
it's still there
i just hate the look i hate that
okay i'm probably gonna die being
cornered in here but i just gotta grab
this one
oh my god i'm dead i'm dead i'm a dead
man i'm a dead man that walks around i'm
a dead man that walks
i'm a dead man walking i'm walking dead
the walking dead the show
oh my god i'm dead and i'm walking i'm
walking with dead legs i got dead
in my legs
oh my god
[Applause]
well it's really important to know where
those last few are before he comes and
gets you
that's the deal i'm not gonna drive
maybe you can try it and you can be over
yourself the link is in the description
but that was pretty good i like that
could he it had a lot of like visual
ambiance it was really good i feel like
it could have done better with the sound
but it still did a pretty good job
altogether this was a good one
very uh very slender type but you know
honestly the recipe does work and not as
many people are doing that recipe
anymore so i liked it
not bad
that was three scary games thank you
everybody so much for watching be sure
to hit that like button for whatever
reason the like button is needed to be
hit
and remember to subscribe maybe i don't
know what that button actually does down
there but either way
i appreciate you being here have a good
day take care of yourselves and
uh don't not look both ways when you
cross the road have a good one
all right see you around
[Music]
you